[Music]
yes i am starting a new youtube channel
i'm actually really really excited about
this project of mine it's a project
that's been brewing since the beginning
of pandemic i just never took the steps
to make it happen
until now as you guys know i love
cooking and every time i make a cooking
video on this channel so many of you
guys are asking me to start
a separate channel just for food so i'm
doing exactly that
but yeah i'm still in the planning stage
hopefully in a month or so i will be
launching but in the meantime i've been
writing a few of the episodes and i've
been using this thing called grammarly
to help me write the episodes this video
is sponsored by
grammarly so what is grammarly grammarly
is a digital writing assistant that
helps you to write more clearly and more
effectively it's super easy to use you
can download it as a browser extension
so it's easily integrated into your life
when you're using chrome
or safari whatever web browser you use
now they do have a free
and a premium version the free version
is great for
basic corrections basically double
checking your work checking for spelling
errors
grammar errors punctuation errors but if
you upgrade to the premium version which
i've been using they have advanced
features that will help you save
so much more time when you work so when
i write i tend to especially when i'm
word vomiting i tend to use
same vocabulary over and over and over
and over now when you read it back it
sounds repetitive so in the upgraded
version there is a feature called
premium vocabulary suggestions
and it basically helps you avoid using
the same words over and over and over
and over
and over and they also have a feature
called clarity suggestions it basically
helps you get your message across and it
removes unnecessary and redundant words
so with this new project in mind it
requires a lot of writing of me and by
using grammarly it's been helping me
meet a deadline that i've set out for
myself but the thing about writing is
i'm not exactly the biggest fan
of writing i think there's someone out
there that might enjoy it more than i do
but what i love to do is
film and piece of video together and
that's where i really find the greatest
joy in my work so grammarly has come in
to help me proof
all my writing helping me move forward
in the process of bringing this new
channel to you guys
so save time on your work and your
emails with grammarly go to
grammarly.com
tiffincakes to sign up for a free
account and get 20 off grammarly premium
today to help you save time
and work more efficiently alright so
today i'm going to be filming
a little segment for my new channel a
little behind the scenes if you will but
like i said it says
it's going to be a channel about food
storytelling and
filmmaking so like you saw in the last
video i just got a brand new camera i've
been having a lot of fun with it like i
said last time it's been a long time
since i've had a
like production quality camera on this
channel i've been shooting a lot
on uh point and shoots but i want to
bring you guys along on this process of
mine
as i build out this new channel and
those of you guys that are major foodies
and are just really into like food
culture i
think you're gonna love this i'm trying
to get three episodes done before i
actually launch it so i can get a little
stockpile going on but yeah anyways
today i'm gonna be filming myself
filming
so i'm filming myself filming
me cooking on the menu for tonight big
stew now normally when i film cooking
videos on this channel i rarely
break i mean well one i didn't have a
production camera like this
but rarely did i even break out
production lights here we go
action
i have not broken out these lights in a
long time i don't know if they work
anymore
let's find out
all right it is bright in here but they
are alive
all right so one of the reasons why i'm
starting a new channel too is
through my work on youtube all these
years
and vlogging and then making these
cooking videos on this particular
channel and also having worked on our
new business with the matcha stuff
i realized i'd love photographing food
and making it look as delicious as
possible and then even when i'm editing
it
really enhancing the sounds and making
it like just invigorating all the
feelings of hunger
i really really like and i enjoy doing
that all right let's begin cooking
this is my chuck roast
do
see these uh this gorillapod with uh
three legs
i take two of the legs tap it over my
shoulder like this either points forward
or down or wherever i'm trying to shoot
right now i'm gonna get a bowl of celery
okay rule of thumb don't drop your brand
new camera on the floor
luckily camera's okay
[Music]
here is my beef stew and um
i hope you guys like the cinematic shots
and that's like a little preview of uh
the new channel
[Music]